could you tell me what we're doing
tonight and why it's such a big night
we're here for an amazing fan event with
a whole host of people to launch the new
trailer for Star Trek Beyond and it's
the 50th anniversary circuit there you
have it it's a big milestone for the
franchise and it's a great opportunity
to share with Paramount was also
dedicating the street and Zachary Quinto
known for his role as mr. Spock in the
rebooted trilogy had the honor of
unveiling the legendary actor Street at
the Star Trek beyond fan even on Fridays
to officially open at Paramount Studios
Leonard Nimoy Way now following the
ceremony the 38 year old actor took to
Instagram calling the tribute the most
humbling moment of my trek experience we
have a passionate fan base I think
that's anything you can ask for from
something you're involved in we all love
one another so much to have that kind of
mirrored back to us by the by the fan
community is fantastic
Star Trek beyond hits theaters on July
22nd